bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur public sénat cet après
midi les sénateurs poursuivent l'examen
de l'article 1 du projet de loi sur la
sécurisation de l'emploi
cet article doit généraliser à partir de
2016 la complémentaire santé pour tous
les salariés
actuellement quatre millions de salariés
n'y accède pas mais pour le front de
gauche
il ne s'agit pas d'un nouveau droit
c'est le moyen pour les assurances
privées de s'enrichir au détriment de la
sécurité sociale et selon le medef c'est
un pactole d'un peu plus de 4 millions
d'euros qui seraient ainsi réalisées du
coup les sénateurs communistes ont
multiplié les amendements sur l'article
1 pour tenter de l'améliorer en
élargissant par exemple la
complémentaire santé aux étudiants ou
alors en tentant de garantir le
remboursement des frais d'optique
mais tous leurs amendements ont été
rejetés tout donc direction l'hémicycle
pour l'examen du projet de loi sur la
sécurisation de l'emploi très bonne
après midi à tous sur notre chaîne la
présidente seul ministre
chers collègues l'objet du présent
amendement c'est de prendre en compte le
caractère collectif de l'adhésion d'une
entreprise à une assurance
complémentaire santé relevant du code
des assurances lorsque cette adhésion
résulte d'une obligation prévue par une
convention de branche ou un accord
professionnel ou interprofessionnel
comme nous venons de le voir c'est
pourquoi l'amendement substitut le terme
d'adhésions à celui de souscription du
contrat ce faisant ils alignent le code
des assurances sur le code de la
sécurité sociale et le code de la
mutualité
c'est à dire qu'il est temps les
dispositions de ces derniers au premier
dans un souci d'égalité de concurrence
en obligeant les complémentaires
relevant du code des assurances à
maintenir les garanties en cas de non
paiement de primes par les entreprises
assurées lorsque celles ci ne sont plus
en capacité de les payer en raison de
difficultés économiques graves s'agit
d'éviter la suspension des droits en
santé oms prévoyance des salariés
pendant cette période de difficultés
économiques pour les salariés
collectivement couverts par une
complémentaire relevant du code des
assurances et ainsi d'éviter à biais de
concurrence entre assurance d'une part
et mutuelles et instituts de prévoyance
d'autre part un exemple de saine
émulation et d'alignement par le haut
des garanties offertes à l'assuré liés
aux vertus de la concurrence et qui nous
ont été rappelés par cette autorité de
la concurrence dont il a été largement
question
merci merci monsieur vanlerenberghe
je vais demander l'avis du monsieur le
rapporteur sur cet amendement
merci et même la présidente
cet amendement apporté propose plutôt
une précision juridique en remplaçant le
terme souscription par adhésion dans les
articles que j'ai pu lire concernant les
institutions de prévoyance et des
mutuelles
c'est en effet plutôt le terme de
d'adhésion qui est utilisé il me il me
semble donc pas impertinent d'opérer
cette substitution néanmoins pour être
sûr d'être dans les pures juridique
souhaité je demande l'avis du
gouvernement merci monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le ministre la
présidente le rapporteur considère que
ce n'est pas un pertinent et le
gouvernement considère que c'est
pertinent
donc ce qui permettra à cette précision
bienvenue d'être adoptée si vous êtes
d'accord et aux rapporteurs de faire
sauter son un merci monsieur le ministre
je vais donc métro voir l'amendement 640
il ya eu un avis favorable du
gouvernement qui est pour
merci contre abstentions l'amendement
640 est adopté monsieur placez vous
vouliez
d'accord le 257 madame henman madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre sera
porteur c'est un amendement d'appel
parce que j'ai la nette impression que
quand on lit la l'actuel texte
on pourrait considérer que les aligner à
54 cents à 58 permettent à un assureur
privé de mettre en place un réseau de
soins or pour ma part je crois que ce
serait une grosse menace si on pouvait
permettre à des assureurs privés
d'organiser ces réseaux de soins donc je
voudrais savoir si le gouvernement
estime 1 que le texte permet ces réseaux
de soin d'eux s'il le permet tait s'il y
est favorable
merci madame lienemann
je vais demander à monsieur le
rapporteur son avis sur le 200 cet avis
de la commission sur cet amendement
merci même la présidente
mes chers collègues qu'il faut bien
comprendre que les alinéas que cet
amendement veut supprimer ont un double
objet étendre aux mutuelles l'obligation
de maintenir le contrat en cas de défaut
de paiement des cotisations par une
entreprise et également permettre aux
sociétés d'assurance de proposer dans le
contrat d action sociale collective
l'amendement donc aurait pour
conséquence de supprimer des
dispositions qui précisément permettent
de mettre sur pied de mettre sur un pied
d'égalité les institutions de prévoyance
les mutuelles et des sociétés
d'assurance il en a été longuement
question ce matin pour proposer des
contrats de complémentaire santé aux
partenaires sociaux aux entreprises ces
alinéas à mon point de vue n'ont a
priori pas de rapport avec les réseaux
de soins
comme mentionné dans l'exposé des motifs
de l'amendement
c'est pour ces raisons un avis
défavorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur même vie
merci madame inman oui si j'ai bien
compris mais j'ai pas une réponse très
net sur le fait parce que le problème
c'est les activités sociales dont on
parle
peuvent-elles ou non être assimilés à
des réseaux de soins
j'ai bien entendu que le rapporteur
considère que ces noms qu'il me fait un
signe négatif qui confirme ce point je
souhaite que soient bien clairement
explicitées dans le compte rendu et à
partir de ce moment là bien évidemment
je retire mon amendement
merci madame inman il est repris très
bien très bien pourquoi ces versets l'on
reprend par prudence parce que on a ici
un amendement d'appel et ça confirme
tout à fait ce que j'ai dit lors du
rappel au règlement c'est qu'on aurait
bien eu besoin d'avoir l'éclairage de
madame la ministre de la santé ici pour
nous éclairer sur cette question c'est
pas une question facile la question des
réseaux de soins n'y a pas de réponse
tranchée
voilà et je crois que cet amendement il
trouve son sa justification justement
donc temps que madame la ministre de la
santé n'aura pas répondu comme nous
l'aurions souhaité à notre demande
d'éclaircissement bien nous reprenons
cet amendement et nous le voterons pour
ce qui nous concerne
merci mais c'est la fin monsieur le
rapporteur messier me nice comme vous
voulez non une petite précision à
l'attention de monsieur watrin là où
fait un travail sérieux sur le texte qui
nous est proposé et lorsque je vous
donne ses assurances je les confirme ce
qu'on appelle les actions sociales en
l'occurrence concerne des actions de
prévention qui ne sont rien qui ne
peuvent en rien s'assimiler aux réseaux
de soins
les actions de prévention
sur le plan de la santé dans un secteur
comme la boulangerie sur les problèmes
d'asthme et autres ça ne ressemble en
rien aux réseaux de soins
merci monsieur rapporté un monsieur le
ministre la présidente je voulais
simplement rassurer sur sénateurs sur
les compétences du ministre qui est
présent qui est capable aussi d'exprimer
sur d'autres sujets que strictement et
donc je veux ici parce qu'il y là il a
considéré me semble-t-il
et je ne peux pas lui en vouloir je ne
peux pas lui en vouloir que je ne serai
pas compétent pour répondre sur ce sujet
et puis une autre personne pourrait être
compétentes pour répondre sur ce sujet
mais comme il est parfaitement compétent
pour me poser la question je suis
compétent pour lui répondre dans le même
sens que le rapporteur ça n'a rien à
voir
l'action sociale n'a rien à voir avec le
réseau de soins et n'est donc en rien
concerné c'est clair voyez chez
compétents merci messieurs
mais si l'ancien ministre tire
l'amendement
c'est impossible je retire vous le
redire la reprise de l'amendement et je
sais que ce qui vient d'être dit par
monsieur le ministre j'ai aucune raison
de contester sans eau de douter de ces
paroles donc ça sera inscrit dans le
rapport mais je crois simplement que il
ya un vrai débat sur les réseaux de
soins et que ce débat là bien sûr et ça
nécessitera du temps mais en tout cas on
aurait eu la ministre de la santé comme
je lé demandé dans le rapport
dans mon rappel au règlement ça aurait
été encore mieux
ça aurait été encore mieux
merci merci monsieur le prince nous en
venons à l'amendement à l'amendement 575
monsieur place et j'ai président placé
merci à la présidence le ministre shah
collègues
cet amendement vise à élargir le champ
d'application de l'article l 1226 1 du
code du travail aux anciens salariés
tout cela ne doit pas se faire au
préjudice des échanges entre la
présidente assassiner le président café
bien évidemment que je ne veux pas
déranger
cet article l 1226 à l'ag même pas
besoin des coups je voudrais juste peu
près de discrétion s'applique
aujourd'hui aux salariés ayant au moins
un an d'ancienneté dans l'entreprise et
le sujet sérieux et les couvre en cas
d'incapacité à travailler résultant d'un
accident d'une maladie ces salariés ont
droit à une indemnité complémentaire à
l'allocation journalière
les anciens salariés c'est le sujet des
différents amendements j'ai pu présenter
ne sont pas pris en compte dans ce
dispositif autant l'article premier du
projet de loi dont nous débattons
actuellement vise à garantir aux
individus les moins protégés en termes
de couverture santé une protection face
justement aux risques de l'existence
aussi ses anciens salariés
particulièrement fragile donc il me
paraît important et qu'il bénéficie de
l'ouverture au même titre que les
salariés lorsqu'ils se retrouvent à
l'incapacité travailler suite à une
maladie ou un accident
cette indemnité complémentaire est une
aide non négligeable pour les personnes
à l'incapacité et c'est une mesure de
justice sociale et d'équité que de la
garantir également aux anciens salariés
c'est le sens de cette proposition
merci merci monsieur le président mais
si le rapporteur
merci madame la présidente je veux
apporter une réponse aussi précise que
possible
l'article l 12 26 1 du code du travail
prévoit sous certaines conditions qu'un
salarié ayant au moins un an
d'ancienneté bénéficient d'une indemnité
complémentaire aux indemnités
journalières maladie de la sécurité
sociale est versée par l'employeur en
cas d'absence il ya une incapacité votre
amendement propose d'élargir cette
disposition aux anciens salariés se
retrouvant au chômage il
qui bénéficie d'un maintien de droits à
titre gratuit durant au plus un an
alors votre amendement peut avoir des
conséquences financières non marginal et
que je suis dans l'incapacité pour ma
part d'évaluer sur les contrats de
prévoyance
en outre et surtout il est
contradictoire avec l'alinéa 25 qui
prévoit que le maintien des droits ne
peut pas avoir pour conséquence le
versement d'indemnités supérieures aux
allocations chômage
c'est donc une invitation retrait merci
messieurs rapportèrent monsieur
ministres autorise t il parfaitement
précis et techniquement imparable donc
j'ai la même demande
c'est une demande de retrait monsieur le
ministre
appareil merci merci bien je vais donc
mettre aux voix au noir non monsieur
monsieur placer ce que vous me direz non
ne vous le dirais pas très bien donc je
vais le mettre aux voix
il a un amendement qui a été l'objet de
deux demandes de retrait qui est pour
merci contre merci abstentions un
amendement n'est pas adopté on arrive à
l'article 1er j'ai été saisi d'une
demande de scrutin public et je me
demande s'il ya des explications de vote
sur l'article 1er alain gautier morin
apparemment oui madame la présidente
quelques mots avant le vote de cet
article 1er je crois qu'on peut dire que
le débat nourri que nous avons eues ch à
ce propos
ainsi que les amendements adoptés en
commission des affaires sociales et lors
des travaux dans l'hémicycle ne nous
conduise pas à porter je le déplore une
appréciation autre que celle que nous
avions présentées lors de nos
interventions sur cet article
le gouvernement et sa majorité font
comme si l'adoption de cet article avait
au final aucune conséquence sur le
régime obligatoire de base tels qu'ils
existent à travers la sécurité sociale
ni aucune conséquence sur les relations
qui existent entre celui ci et la
diversité des offres proposées par les
mutuelles ou les sociétés d'assurance à
l'assemblée madame la ministre des
affaires sociales et de la santé a
déclaré je cite les choses doivent être
claires sur ce point il n'y a pas dans
l'article premier du projet qui vous est
proposée une construction une
reconstruction ou un aménagement global
de notre système de santé qu'il s'agisse
des relations entre l'assurance maladie
obligatoire et les régimes et les
organismes complémentaires ou de la
conception de l'organisation des
dispositifs complémentaires
fin de citation eh bien nous pensons que
cette voie n'est pas là abane et
j'observe que certains députés
socialistes s'en inquiètent également
puisque monsieur germain rapporteur sur
ce texte à l'assemblée nationale n'a pas
hésité à présenter cet article 1er ou à
le qualifier d'obama caire pour les
complémentaires fin de citation non ce
n'est pas la bonne voie car il n'aura
échappé à personne que l'obamacare à la
différence de notre système de
protection sociale repose
essentiellement sur les assurances
privées
car c'est moi une manière d'affirmer que
contrairement à ce que l'on pourrait
croire de prime abord les grands
gagnants de cet article ne seront pas
les organismes mutualistes qui ne
poursuivent pas de but lucratif
mais les assurances privées
et qui n'ont qu'un objectif maximiser
les profits pour les distribuer aux
actionnaires les groupes dont il s'agit
dont certains gèrent d'ailleurs les
régimes de sécurité sociale de base
obligatoire des assurances entendent
bien profiter de la manne financière qui
s'engage avec cet article
cela participera je le pense sincèrement
à la marche id une marchandisation de
notre système de santé c'est tout un
processus qui peut s'accélérer
madame la ministre des affaires sociales
et de la santé
là a déclaré devant les députés et donc
en quelque sorte elles reconnaissent que
je viens de dire je la cite les
couvertures complémentaires sont elles
dans une logique de marché dont
d'individualisation des risques donc fi
de la solidarité
plus on élargit la base sur laquelle
s'applique la couverture complémentaire
mieux on est à même de proposer une
couverture de qualité ainsi plus on
généralise la couverture complémentaire
plus on se rapproche d'un dispositif de
mutualisation positif et bien tout ça
n'est ce pas simplement proposé de
renoncer petit à petit et chemin faisant
de donner des gages à la commission
européenne qui toujours plus soucieuse
de la réduction des déficits publics que
des droits des femmes et des hommes
propose ni plus ni moins que de mettre
en concurrence la sécurité sociale avec
les assurances privées
en réalité c'est ce que je disais à
l'instant on assiste progressivement un
mouvement continu de basculement de la
prise en charge des dépenses de santé de
la sécurité sociale vers les mutuelles
le 10 septembre dernier la drees a rendu
un rapport public portant sur la
situation des comptes nationaux de la
santé en 2010 selon les comptes
nationaux nationaux de la santé publique
les organismes complémentaires ont
supporté en 2011 une part plus
importante des dépenses de santé de nos
concitoyens puisque leur participation
est passée de 13 5% en 2010 à 13 7% en
progressivement année après année les
contrats complémentaires joue un rôle de
plus en plus importants proportionnelle
au désengagement de la sécurité sociale
voilà comment en renforçant le caractère
obligatoire de ces contrats et en
puisant dans les ressources de la
sécurité sociale s'opère un basculement
au déficit du solidaire vers le
contributif le groupe crc ne votera donc
pas cet article 1er merci madame
gonthier-maurin la parole et à monsieur
cardio oui madame la présidente monsieur
deux minutes je suis à collègues je
reviendrai tout simplement ou aux propos
vous avez tenus lors de la discussion
générale où j'avais dit que le groupe
ump voyait d'un oeil assez favorable cet
accord mais qui avait quelques pierres
d'achoppement qui nous chagrine est et
au premier rang de ces pierres
d'achoppement cette fameuse clause de
désignation mais le manque de
concurrence est pluralité donc puisque
le sénat dans sa sagesse a accepté notre
amendement concernant la suppression de
cette clause de désignation ce qu'était
ce qui a été confortée par l'adoption
des amendements moi je fais pas de
particularisme jeudi la sagesse du sénat
donc des amendements de de nos amis
centristes qui ont aussi institué le
pluralisme dans la recommandation
eh bien nous avons obtenu en partie
satisfaction même si les amendements
l'amendement de souplesse que nous
avions espéré voir adopter concernant la
simplification de des démarches
administratives pour les entreprises de
moins de 10 personnes n'ont pas abouti
mais malgré cela et compte tenu de ce
vote ce matin et bien le vote ump votre
a favorablement à l'article merci
monsieur cardio la parole est à monsieur
là sera oui à ce stade des débats force
est de constater que nous divergeons sur
le sens que nous entendons donner à
l'avenir de nos systèmes de protection
sociale
venons nous faisons pour notre part le
choix dans l'intérêt des salariés comme
des étudiants des retraités dont nous
avons soulevé le cas que vous rend
forcier la protection sociale
obligatoire de base c'est-à-dire le
socle de sécurité sociale dont vous avez
parlé vous même monsieur le ministre
force est de constater que vous faites
le choix dans la réalité de ce texte
d'une autre orientation puisque en
définitive les orientations qui sont
choisis aboutiront affaiblir la sécurité
sociale par de nouvelles exonérations de
cotisations sociales accordées aux
employeurs alors nous divergeons
forcément car pour nous plutôt que
d'étendre le champ des contrats
d'assurance complémentaire l'urgence
nous semblerait plutôt être au retour de
la prise en charge 100 % des dépenses de
santé dentaire et optique compris j'ai
soulevé aussi durant les débats
plusieurs questions à ce sujet par la
sécurité sociale il semble que vous y
renonciez d'où la nécessité que vous
posez d'amplifier le recours à la
complémentaire santé vous fait
d'ailleurs passé cette généralisation
comme une avancée sociale
oubliant au passage de préciser que
contrairement à certains des amendements
que nous avions proposé que vous avez
écarté ces complémentaires pourront être
payés pour moitié seulement pas par les
salariés par les employeurs alors que
actuellement par les employeurs lors qu
actuellement les cotisations maladie
sont prises en charge à 98% sur par les
employeurs cela veut dire un coût de 30
à 40 euros allez à la louche comme sa
part par salarié
alors que les travailleurs les salariés
sont déjà largement fragilisé le fait
que l'employeur supporte une somme
équivalente ne changera rien selon nous
à cette situation et pour les foyers
dont je parle et nous en connaissons
toutes et tous dans nos villes et dans
nos départements
cet effort keith leur sera demandé va
correspondre
et ce n'est pas rien en gros budget qui
est souvent dédiées à l'alimentation
pour les ménages les plus modestes
ça nous semble être les limites de ce
système qui qu'on le veuille ou non
repose sur les capacités contributives
de nos concitoyens alors notre
proposition de renforcement de la
sécurité sociale jusqu'à parce que nous
sommes pas pour prendre les choses tout
au rien dès maintenant jusqu'à lui
permettre la prise en charge à 100 %
notre proposition répond à une autre
logique puisque son fondement est le
suivant il correspond base même de la
sécurité sociale chacun cotise selon ses
moyens perçoit selon ses besoins
notre proposition de retour un système
pleinement solidaire s'accompagne
d'ailleurs d'une proposition forte que
je ne fais pas là il c'est pas un scoop
ni révélation plutôt que de faire
financer la couverture santé par les
salariés nous proposons comme nous
l'avons fait à l'occasion de la dernière
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale ou à bien d'autres occasions
précédemment de taxer les revenus
financiers on parle de la finance
aujourd'hui on voit les masses d'argent
considérables qui sont extraits de
l'économie et de l'utilité sociale et
bien la spéculation doit être mise à
contribution afin de contribuer au
financement de notre système de santé
on ne pourra dire que le groupe crc ne
fait que critiquer nous proposons nous
proposons et pas seulement aujourd'hui
avec les ressources générées par 7 me
la sécurité sociale bénéficierait d'un
second souffle et je dois dire que dans
ce système le recours aux assurances
complémentaires deviendrai marginal
secondaire voire facultatif on sait
pourtant aujourd'hui compte tenu des
mauvais remboursements opérés par la
sécurité sociale que de plus en plus de
nos concitoyens renoncent aux soins et
ça c'est vraiment une question qui doit
nous interroger
quand ils ne peuvent se doter d'une
mutuelle il ya donc bien un constat
commun que progressivement les mutuelles
sont devenus indispensables pour pouvoir
bénéficier d'un accès réel aux soins
mais pour nous je le répète et cela a
été dit il faudrait d'abord pour régler
cette question renforcer ce socle de
sécurité sociale que vous avez évoqué
monsieur le ministre vous même merci
chers collègues la parole et à monsieur
vanlerenberghe
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre
chers collègues bien entendu je les dis
d'ailleurs dans la discussion générale
l'arbre de la désignation ne doit pas
cacher qui a conduit à quelques
désaccords entre nous ne doit pas cacher
la forêt de cette complémentaire cette
extension de la complémentaire santé à
tous les salariés
c'est ça l'essentiel de cet article
premier donc c'est la raison bien sûr
pour laquelle surtout tel qu'il a été
amendé par nos soins et par les soins de
nos collègues de l'ump
et par aussi certains collègues du rdse
nous le voterons pour l'état tout en
sachant très bien que puisqu'il y aura
une seconde lecture sur un des points
particuliers sur l'aléa 30 sur le
ministre nous l'a rappelé tout à l'heure
que on avisera évidemment en fin de
parcours sur notre vote définitif
mais je crois qu'il faut retenir
essentiellement le progrès essentiel qui
est aujourd'hui législatif mais qui
tenait tellement à coeur des signataires
de cet accord national
interprofessionnel comme étant
effectivement une contrepartie notable
pour favoriser bien sur la santé des
salariés et pour équilibrer en quelque
sorte
l'accord vis-à-vis des entreprises du
patronat donc nous nous félicitons de la
discussion je crois qu'elle a été
effectivement très large même si à mon
goût est la durée peut être un peu
longtemps mais nous respectons
évidemment les avis de chacun et le
temps c'est le temps
merci merci chers collègues la parole
est à mme alain pasquet
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues outre le
fait que l'évaluation de l'article
premier en terme financier pour le moins
ne se détermine
car ils ont des coûts et non d'éventuels
produits qui pourraient être tirés de la
généralisation de la couverture
complémentaire santé aux salariés qui en
sont privés quelques éléments nous
interpelle d'étude d'impact reprises
dans le rapport de notre collègue
jeannerot indique que la mise en place
de la complémentaire santé constitue une
série de coûte ainsi estimé selon le
champ d'application pris en compte 375 à
540 millions d'euros de coût pour la
sécurité sociale
d'abord puis entre 1.5 et 2,1 milliards
d'euros pour l'état
et enfin entre 2 et 3 milliards d'euros
pour les entreprises sachant toutefois
que les abondements des entreprises
constitue une charge déductible
ce qui signifie que le tiers est
assimilable à une réduction d'impôt il
est plus juste de réduire d'autant le
coût pour les entreprises
par contre les dépenses exposées pour
l'état et la sécurité sociale semble bel
et bien quasi certaine nous sommes donc
en présidant un dispositif coûtant au
moins 1,9 milliard d'euros aux comptes
publics et jusqu'à 2,7 milliards environ
pour un résultat assez hypothétique
puisque rien ne permet aujourd'hui
d'éviter de penser que ce sera le panier
de soins minimum qui sera finalement le
plus souvent sollicités c'est donc là un
nouvel accroissement de la dépense
publique qui se profile on risque même
d'avoir un effet de levier
le simple fait que des assurés sociaux
sollicite des soins auxquels y renoncer
par le passé est un élément
d'accroissement des dépenses de santé
donc alors là quid de l'ondam pour 2014
ceci dit on peut aussi rapproché la
somme mobilisée au titre de cette
extension des complémentaires de celles
aujourd'hui consacrés au financement de
la complémentaire cmu qui s'élève à 2,2
milliards 427 millions d'euros pour 2013
pourtant la question
un nouvel amendement de l'état au fonds
cmu avec une redéfinition de
bénéficiaires de la couverture tant de
base que complémentaires n'aurait elle
pas atteint le même objectif que celui
recherché
a priori par le texte de l'article 1er
en fait à la place de tout cela nous
avons surtout un dispositif au moins
aussi coûteux qui est fait pour
accroître la part des compagnies
d'assurances à but lucratif dans le
financement de la santé publique
ce cheval de troie ce virus de la
marchandisation de la santé que vous
faites ainsi rentrer avec cet article
premier est peut être celui qui va
accompagner demain la réduction sans
cesse plus france plus drastique des
prestations servies par le régime
général
le problème c'est qu'aucun des pays
ayant goûté aux délices de la
privatisation de la santé n'a fait ou ne
fait la démonstration de la pertinence
de la chose nous voterons résolument
contre cet article 1er merci madame pas
ce qu'est la parole est à madame
demontès oui madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre madame mentionnera
porter mes chers collègues donc nous
arrivons maintenant au vote de cet
article 1er de ce projet de loi qui est
un article extrêmement important et les
partenaires sociaux ne s'y sont pas
trompés avec deux éléments sur lesquels
je veux insister l'obligation de
couverture santé collective par les
entreprises avec un socle minimal qui
sera fixé par décret et moi je me
réjouis que dans la discussion monsieur
le ministre ait pu nous apporter un
certain nombre de précisions sur ce que
sera ce décret qui est de nature à
rassurer ceux qui avait quelques doutes
le deuxième élément c'est bien sûr la
portabilité des couvertures santé
prévoyance pour les salariés privés de
laurent privés de leur emploi 1 devenant
demandant d'emplois pendant 12 mois
bien sûr madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues nous ne
sommes pas satisfaits du vote qui a eu
lieu tout à l'heure sur la suppression
de clauses de désignation
on sait bien d'ailleurs de qui vient
cette demande de suppression de clauses
de désignation pour autant et le
ministre l'a dit il y aura une deuxième
délibération sur ce sujet bien que nous
ne soyons pas satisfait que le groupe
socialiste ne soient pas satisfaits de
ce de ce vote
bien évidemment nous allons voter cet
article premier qui respecte
parfaitement l'accord national
interprofessionnel et qui je le rappelle
cet accord national interprofessionnel
qui a été amélioré dans le cadre du
projet de loi a fait l'objet d'un
compromis entre les partenaires sociaux
compromis qui a été respectée par le
gouvernement et qui doit être avec des
aménagements des améliorations encore
respectée par notre assemblée par par le
sénat nous allons bien évidemment voté
cet article le groupe socialiste bien
sûr votre à cet article si madame de
montech la parole est à monsieur
dassault
merci verra présente uniquement vous
dire vous continue des amendements que
nous avons présentés avec ont été
acceptés je voterai pour cet article
la parole est à mme adama eliane assassi
j'étais surprise merci madame la
présidente
donc cet article doit à l'évidence
réjouir le medef qui par la voix de sa
présidente déclaré le 19 mars dernier
lors de son point de presse mensuel je
la cite il faut que l'entreprise et le
libre choix de l'organisme
complémentaires fin de citation une
nécessité martelé jamais justifié et
pour cause il faudrait alors qu'elle
dise clairement que si elle s'oppose aux
clauses désignation succès qu'elle
s'oppose de facto à la possibilité que
permettent ces clauses aux organisations
syndicales de négocier les meilleurs
contrats quand le patronat est plutôt
enclin à négocier les contrats les moins
cher quitte à ce que les prestations
offertes aux salariés soit moins bonne
dans la mesure où dans la mesure où ces
contrats vont permettre aux employeurs
outre de concurrencer la sécurité
sociale ce que vous l'aurez compris nous
ne pouvons accepter
donc ces mesures ces contrats vont
permettre aux employeurs de bénéficier
d'importantes exonérations de
cotisations sociales jusqu'à 2,5
milliards d'euros
il nous semble quand même impératif que
le législateur veille à ce que les
salariés puissent prétendre au
dispositif le plus protecteur
je note d'ailleurs un certain paradoxe
de la part de ceux qui prônent le
respect à tout prix des règles de la
concurrence
donc ils veulent que les employeurs
puissent rester les seuls maîtres à bord
réaffirmant en creux les bienfaits de la
concurrence mais ne rechigne pas à
l'intervention des pouvoirs publics dès
lors que cette dernière prend la forme
d'un financement public via des
exonérations de cotisations sociales
alors c'est une théorie et cette terre
aux théories nous la refusons à double
titre
tout d'abord pour nous des loques des
fonds publics sont mobilisés
il doit y avoir des contreparties clair
et il doit y avoir aussi des obligations
de nos concitoyens
on demande des efforts massifs ne
peuvent admettre qu'en période de crise
on puise dans les caisses des comptes
publics et sociaux sans rien exiger des
bénéficiaires
cette époque est révolue le cic eux doit
être le dernier exemple de ce type
par ailleurs la santé n'est pas un
secteur comme les autres ce n'est je
pense qu'on peut partager cela ce n'est
ni un service anodin
ce n'est pas non plus une marchandise je
sais je sais bien que certains de ce
côté-ci de l'hémicycle voudrait mettre
en concurrence les assurances privées
commerciales mais si si madame debré et
les organismes mutualistes qui ne
poursuivent pas d'objectif lucratif cela
par ailleurs commencé il y à une
décennie avec la séparation des titres
du code de la mutualité conséquences eh
bien les mutuelles ne peuvent plus
financer directement leurs centres de
santé qui les uns après les autres
risquent de fermer comme à marseille
si aucune solution n'est trouvée alors
que chacun s'accorde à dire que ces
structures sont efficaces qu'elles
répondent aux attentes des médecins
comme des populations on accepte que les
règles de la concurrence imposée par
l'europe entraîne leur fermeture
certains dont voudrait même poussé alors
encore plus loin la concurrence en
permettant aux assurances privées de se
substituer un jour à la sécurité sociale
cela est d'ailleurs déjà partiellement
le cas puisque une partie de la sécurité
sociale de base des agriculteurs par
exemple est confiée à une assurance
privée commerciale avec une conséquence
qu'il faut souligner des frais de
gestion bien supérieurs à ceux supportés
par le rsa alors la santé la protection
sociale de base comme complémentaire
mérite des règles particulières et c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous pensons que
cet article premier ne va pas dans le
bon sens et que nous vous appelons à le
rejeter comme nous allons le faire
merci madame ça s'est vu ce président
placé dernier orateur inscrit
et merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues débat
est un peu à fronts renversés notamment
dû au vote de l'amendement ump tout à
l'heure ce qui est bien naturel non pas
le vote de l'amendement ump mais le fait
que ça soit à fronts renversés puisqu'il
ya plusieurs sujets qui sont dans la
discussion l'article m'a d'abord est ce
que c'est une avancée de la
complémentaire santé pour tous oui c'est
évidemment une avancée nous ne pouvons
que nous en réjouir
et il ya de nombreuses précisions qui
ont été apportées par le ministre
parlera porter et par différents
amendements pour faire en sorte qu'il y
ait une réalité une effectivité assez
complémentaire santé pour tous même si
je partage l'inquiétude de mes amis
communistes sur notamment les petites
entreprises et les petites structures ou
des complémentaires santé n'aura pas
forcément une réalité notamment
immédiate c'est à nous de faire en sorte
que ce droit puisse s'exercer réellement
alors sur la question de l' équilibre
entre cette complémentaire santé qui se
rajoute aux systèmes de base de la
sécurité sociale et son risque de à
terme de privatisation j'ai soulevé dans
la discussion générale en mon propos
introductif et oui c'est une vraie
réalité j'interpelle les uns et les
autres parce que je suis certain que si
ce sont bien sûr nos amis communistes
qui après guerre ont mis en place ce
dispositif me souviens aussi que les
gaullistes s'était également attaché à
ce droit fondamental pour les salariés
et je suis persuadé que cette
problématique là public privé n'est pas
que partager dans un clivage droite
gauche et j'attire l'attention de la
réalité de ces cette perspective
et je me permets de faire une petite
digression mais cela me permet de parler
des allocations familiales parce que je
pense que c'est à peu près la même
problématique c'est qu'à un moment qu'on
commence à se dire eh bien on va faire
payer les plus riches en réduisant les
allocations familiales ce n'est pas une
bonne façon d'envisager les choses sur
le plan principe yale et voilà donc ce
sont les ce type de question principale
que nous devons essayer de partager
notamment ici à là
haute assemblée après sur ce sujet de
clauses de désignation l'a vu il ya eu
et mon collègue des essarts sont en
effet l'expression y compris par le vote
au nom du groupe
il y à une interrogation de notre part
est-ce que c'est d'en haut niveau des
branches qu'il faut essayer de
contractualiser la désignation est ce
qu'il faut aller au plus près de
l'entreprise donc on pourrait se dire
les libéraux sont pour au plus près de
l'entreprise où le rapport de forces est
pas pu ne n'est pas forcément meilleur
de façon caricaturale bien sûr mais
forcément meilleur pour le salarié mais
ou alors est-ce que c'est plutôt la
liberté aux le côté libertaire qui fait
que ce serait l'accord de branche serait
plus contraignant et peut-être même
d'ailleurs plus coûteux enfin là le
sujet n'est pas si si clivé à mon avis
que cela d'où le sens du vote de mon
éminent amis des essarts tout à l'heure
qui donc a donné une majorité à cet
amendement
alors vous savez je n'ai pas l'habitude
de me défausser donc bien sûr nous
restons dans la philosophie de ce qui a
été voté
tout à l'heure néanmoins comme le
gouvernement a indiqué qu'il y aurait
une deuxième délibération et étant
peut-être moins réactif que mes amis et
collègues du groupe socialiste qui eux
ont tellement confiance et dans la
première et de la deuxième délibération
et qu' ils votent oui
avec l'amendement ump ou votre ans au
mont louis après que le gouvernement ait
bien pour ma part étant moins réactif
nous allons nous abstenir une abstention
d'attentes avant la deuxième
délibération sur sur cet article
et j'espère que nous pourrons discuter
avec le ministre et le rapporteur plus
précisément sur la question de la clause
de désignation et de l'amendement qui a
été voté tout à l'heure je remercie
merci monsieur le président en place et
alors
j'ai été saisi j'ai été saisi d'une
demande de scrutin public par lé groupe
crc ump et socialistes sur l'article 1er
il va donc être procédé au scrutin
public dans les conditions fixées par
l'article 56 du règlement le scrutin
sera ouvert dans quelques instants
scrutin est ouvert
ce
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est donc clos j'invite les
secrétaires a procédé au dépouillement
du scrutin
résultat du scrutin numéro 197 sur
l'article 1er nombre de votants 347
nombre de suffrages exprimés 333 pour
l'adoption 313 contre 20 le sénat a
adopté l'article premier du projet de
loi relatif à la sécurisation de
l'emploi
mes chers collègues je voulais alerté
notre assemblée
il ya enfin vous de vous permettre de
vous organiser qu'en accord avec
monsieur le ministre nous avons décidé
de suspendre à 19h et de reprendre à 21h
j'en viens maintenant à l'article 1er
bis
y at il des explications de vote sur
l'article 1er bis mme alain pasquer
merci madame la présidente c'est
l'article 1er bis de ce projet de loi
résulte de l'adoption par l'assemblée
nationale d'un amendement déposé par les
députés du groupe socialiste et
républicain
celui ci a pour objet d'étudier comment
moduler ou modifier la politique
d'exonération sociale ou fiscale
actuellement en vigueur afin de
généraliser la couverture complémentaire
et pour reprendre l'objet même de
l'amendement donner aux couvertures
complémentaires une portée universelle
chacun aura donc notée avec cette notion
d'universalité jusqu'à leur attaché à la
surêté social que comme nous l'avons
déjà dit à l'occasion de nos
interventions sur l'article 1er la
volonté du gouvernement réside bien dans
la substitution progressive de notre
système actuel par un système fondé sur
les contrats d'assurance complémentaire
notre groupe n'est pas favorable aux
exonérations de cotisations sociales qui
constitue personne ne l'ignorent des
trappes à bas salaires la cour des
comptes l'a déjà dit l'enjeu n'est donc
pas pour nous d'étudier comment mieux
ventiler ses hôtes cette exonération
mais de les supprimer la question n'est
pas de les orienter en direction des
régimes complémentaires et de faire en
sorte que les ressources nouvelles
issue de la suppression de ces
exonérations exemptions d'assiette
alimenté
comme elle devrait théoriquement le
faire la sécurité sociale lui permettant
afin d'assurer des dépenses de santé
qu'elle ne couvre pas ou pas assez comme
les frais liés aux soins dentaires ou
optiques qui plus est nous avons onze
savons qu'il existe un débat sur
l'opportunité de créer notamment pour
les retraités des mécanismes
d'incitation financière leur permettant
de souscrire à des assurances santé
complémentaires
certains proposent par exemple que cette
aide financière prennent la forme d'un
crédit d'impôt
cette question pourrait d'ailleurs
parfaitement être abordées dans ce
rapport
si nous n'y auront rien des difficultés
que rencontrent nos concitoyennes et
concitoyens les plus âgés pour accéder
aux soins
nous savons pertinemment que la solution
ne réside pas dans les contrats
d'assurance complémentaire
ceux ci tiennent en effet compte de
l'âge des bénéficiaires et ont tendance
à croître au fur et à mesure que les
bénéficiaires vieillissent or plus l'âge
avance plus les besoins en santé sont
importants plus les besoins augmentent
plus le coût des contrats
complémentaires progresse cela signifie
que même avec un crédit d'impôt les
dépenses supportées par les retraites
des retraités seront appelés à croître
alors même que leur pouvoir d'achat
lui ne progresse pas on voit bien que le
recours aux assurances complémentaires
n'est pas la bonne solution
qui plus est qu adviendra-t-il demain de
nos concitoyens qui en raison de la
faiblesse ne pourront pas bénéficier
d'une réduction fiscale
certains avancent l'idée de la création
d'un chèque santé destinée à leur
faciliter l'acquisition d'une mutuelle
complémentaire
mais ces mécanismes qui existent déjà
fonctionne mal le taux de non recours
dispositif d' aide à l'acquisition d'une
mutuelle complémentaire étant assez
élevé mais pour cause même avec un
soutien financier de plus en plus de nos
concitoyens ne peuvent recourir à de
tels contrats et préféré renoncer plutôt
que de ne plus pouvoir se loger ou
manger correctement pour les personnes
âgées comme pour les précaires mais au
delà comme pour l'ensemble des salariés
la question n'est pas de savoir comment
favoriser le recours
contrats complémentaires mais comment
faire en sorte que le renforcement de
notre sécurité sociale de base afin
qu'elles puissent répondre à tous les
besoins et qu'elles rendent inutile le
recours à ces contrats je remercie
merci madame pasquet il n'y a pas
d'autres demandes d'explications de vote
sur l'article 1er bis
je le mets donc aux voix qui est pour
merci contre merci abstentions l'article
1er bis est adoptée à l'article 1er
terre j'ai une demande de paroles de
michel le scouarnec
vous avez la parole cher collègue madame
la présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues le régime local
d'alsace-moselle héritage de l'histoire
constitue sous certains aspects la
mutuelle complémentaire obligatoire des
salariés retraités alsaciens et
mosellans moyenne à un taux de
cotisation fixée à 5% du salaire
cela reste plutôt modeste le régime
complète en général de manière plutôt
heureuse des prestations servies par le
régime général de sécurité sociale gérée
directement par les seuls assurés
sociaux eux-mêmes obligatoire pour
l'ensemble des salariés et retraités des
trois départements le régime local
compte aujourd'hui plus d'un million six
cent mille cotisants et plus de deux
millions et demi d endroits au total sa
situation financière est plutôt saine
avec un léger excédent de trésorerie
les produits et charges s'équilibrant
aux alentours de 450 millions d'euros de
ressources essentiellement des
cotisations et d'emplois essentiellement
des prestations versées aux
bénéficiaires cotisant au demeurant dans
le passé quand le régime local a connu
d'exercices déficitaires
les taux de cotisation furent relevés
pour apurer le passif et revenir à une
situation plus conforme
on pourrait évidemment se demander ce
que le rapport prévu par l'article 1er
terre va bien apporter à la situation du
régime local d'alsace moselle
si ce n'est pour comparer ce qui ne sera
pas forcément comparable puisque ce
régime est obligatoire et qu'il est
surtout interprofessionnelles et
intergénérationnelles à la vérité le
régime local d'alsace moselle
peut constituer sur certains débats en
cours une bonne manière d'approcher la
question de l'accès au soin le régime
d'alsace morin moselle à une réalité ils
assurent une couverture complémentaire
de bonne qualité et même de qualité
supérieure en bien des domaines à
l'ensemble des cotisants et endroits du
régime
je pense même sa collec à l'encontre des
aspirations de quelques-uns des héros de
l'assurance de groupe dont les
cotisations se perdent dans la myriade
des méandres des compagnies d'assurance
il faut se garder de mettre en question
le régime local à jacques alsaco
mosellan le régime local équilibre est
gérée par ses propres bénéficiaires a
d'une certaine manière participé de
l'efficacité économique de la région
il s'est développé on peut fort bien
pensé que le régime local la qualité de
prestations qu'ils assurent ils soient
pour quelque chose de la même manière
que la mise en cause de l'emploi dans
l'économie locale peut constituer un
obstacle à sa pérennité
mais nous pourrions presque dire aux
assureurs attirés par les perspectives
ouvertes par l'article 1er qu'il va leur
falloir faire une croix sur l'alsace et
la moselle poursuit causé à leurs
futures courses aux clients potentiels
ico venait ici de le rappeler merci
merci monsieur le scouarnec
nous en venons vote sur l'article 1er
terre y at il des demandes
d'explications de vote sur l'article je
ne vois pas je vais donc mettre aux voix
l'article premier ter qui est pour
merci contre abstentions
l'article premier ter est adoptée sur
l'article 1er quater j'ai une demande de
parole de monsieur à train oui l'article
premier de ce projet de loi relatifs à
la couverture complémentaire s'est
enrichi après débat à l'assemblée
nationale d'un article 1er quater
résultant de l'adoption d'un amendement
présenté par le groupe socialiste
prévoyant que le gouvernement remette
prochainement un rapport sur les
modalités de prise en charge de la
portabilité des couvertures santé
prévoyance pour les salariés
dans le cas où une entreprise est en
situation de liquidation judiciaire ce
rapport qui s'inscrit dans la continuité
des dispositions dont nous avons
précédemment discuté à savoir la
généralisation des assurances
complémentaires santé soulève toutefois
une question importante
comment prétendre construire en effet un
dispositif universel s'appliquant à
toutes et tous indépendamment de leur
statut quand dans le même temps les
salariés victimes en quelque sorte de la
liquidation judiciaire de leur
entreprise ne pourrait pas prétendre à
la portabilité de leur contrat comme
l'ensemble des autres salariés
qui plus est le rapport la cour des
comptes la teste la précarité entraîne
la précarité et le basculement du statut
de salarié privé indemnisés à celui ne
bénéficions plus de l'assurance chômage
mais de couverture sociale il faut bien
dire minimaliste entraîne un phénomène
que l'on pourrait décrire comme étant
une surprécarisation auquel il faut bien
évidemment trouver des réponses
je souscris donc avec mon groupe à
l'objectif que poursuit ce rapport
toutefois il me semble important que le
gouvernement puisse nous apporter
quelques précisions en effet cet article
prévoit que la continuité des droits
pourrait passer par un fonds de
mutualisation dont la rédaction prévoit
qu'il peut être existants ou à créer
cette rédaction est relativement
différente de la rédaction de
l'amendement initial qui faisait
explicitement référence au fond ces murs
ce fonds n'est plus aux joueurs
aujourd'hui alimenté que par les
mutuelles c'est à dire en fait de
manière indirecte par les mutualistes si
ce fonds est appelé à financer cette
portabilité des organismes qui
concourent à son financement les
organismes complémentaires mutuelles
assurances instituts de prévoyance
n'auront d'autre choix que d'augmenter
leurs tarifs et par voie de conséquence
d'entraîner un mouvement de
démutualisation pour les personnes les
plus démunies
nous pourrions al'inverse imaginer ce
que nous réclamons depuis toujours la
taxation des revenus financiers pour
permettre à tous les salariés privés
d'emploi indépendamment de leur statut à
une prise en charge à 100% 100% par la
sécurité sociale des frais engagés
en attendant d'y parvenir et sans
préjuger des travaux pourriez-vous
cependant monsieur le ministre nous dire
si une autre piste de réflexion que le
fonds cmu est envisagé en cas de
création d'un fonds nouveaux nous dire
quelle pourrait être la nature des
ressources qui abonderait ce fonds merci
monsieur joffrin y at il une demande
d'explications de vote sur l'article 1er
quater je n'en vois pas je vais donc
mettre aux voix cet article 1er quater
qui est pour
merci qui est contre abstention
l'article 1er quater est adopté
madame demontès oui madame la présidente
et excusez moi de prendre la parole à ce
moment là c'était juste pour rectifier
une erreur que nous avons fait et de
bien vouloir sur cet article
à noter que jean pierre godefroy
s'abstient je vous remercie madame
démonter sacs des données de votre mise
au point elle sera publiée au journal
officiel et figurera dans l'analyse
politique du scrutin
après l'article le premier quater un
amendement 539 rectifiée présentée par
monsieur dassault c'est même la
présidente je lis qu'il apparaît de plus
en plus que le personnel des entreprises
n'est pas du tout conscient des
problèmes de gestion l'entreprise et
jean fonctionnement est de même pour les
syndicats par manque d'information c'est
pourquoi cet amendement propose que
chaque entreprise fasse crise et il
somme une véritable formation clinique à
tout son personnel par les sociétés se
faisait ainsi qu'aux syndicats
cette formation devant ainsi permettre à
tous les salariés de prendre mieux
conscience dans quel contexte économique
évolue leur entreprise sur le plan
national et international
face à la concurrence au point deux
coups
le prix de revient de monnaie de
trésorerie de qualité et cetera
une fois mieux informés sur le programme
hic le personnel devra être aussi fort
mais son évolution interne de
l'évolution d'entreprise commandes
contrat résultats échecs et ses deals en
compte d'exploitation
ils devraient savoir que les partenaires
de l'entreprise sont quatre actionnaires
salariés syndicats et clients qui
déterminent eux la lyre l'entreprise
pendant commandes et qu'il faut donc
satisfaire par dessous tout tous ses
partenaires doivent travailler en équipe
pour être efficace et non ennemis de
classe c'est l'évidence
tout le sera il devrait pouvoir
participer plus largement aussi à
l'enrichissement de l'entreprise dans
une réserve de participation égale du
dante est ce que j'ai situé à dassault
aviation depuis plus de 20 ans enfin
jeune pharmacien lui devrait aussi être
profitable aux syndicats qui en
comprendrez mieux le fonctionnement
c'est pourquoi je vous propose cet
amendement qui transformerait et
relations sociales dans l'entreprise en
supprimant et construit par leur
compréhension de ce qui se passe et du
relations du rôle de chacun pour que
chacun travaille en fonction les
intérêts de l'entreprise des salariés
les syndicats et surtout des clients y
ont vendu leur fille merci chers
collègues je vais donc demander l'avis
la commission monsieur le rapporteur sur
cet amendement 539 rectifier merci ma
présidente vous l'avez compris notre
collègue d'assaut préconise dans ce
cadre là une formation obligatoire à
l'économie aux principes de gestion pour
l'ensemble des salariés
je voudrais lui faire observer que cette
ce projet de loi n'a pas vocation à
repenser le contenu de la formation
professionnelle et bien des questions
sont posées par son amendement qui est
hors sujet me semble-t-il par rapport à
ce texte
c'est donc une invitation retrait sinon
avis défavorable merci monsieur lui
rapportant
mais ma vie je vous remercie monsieur
assange vous voulez vous exprimer
qui veut s'exprimer
côté jeunes arrivent ça ne coûte rien à
l'état
côtoyer au budget tout simplement une
nouvelle façon de concevoir les
relations grand prix qui ces ricains par
une formation économique
bon je ne demande rien mais je suis fait
article était acceptée est obligatoire
pour les entreprises ce qui le gêne
personne cela fermerait favoriserait
l'activité sociale auquel vous avez
intérêt de façon que chacun le travail
en bonne connaissance de cause de
l'intérêt l'entreprise pour le saluer
avec l'intéressement
on bénéfice avec les salles et kaki
qu'on aurait peut-être les intérêts de
chacun car il faut que les canines large
en coopération en équipe et pas en lutte
alors voila moi je souhaiterais que vous
acceptiez amendement pour green coûte
rien à personne mais qui quand même
presque les choses et au but en plus
qu'il ne le faut pas aujourd'hui et qui
oublient informer les gens et qui font
oublier informer leurs parcelles au
simple fait qu'au fond tout le monde
travaille ensemble on n'est pas les uns
contre les autres
je suis à l'écart et avec salariés et
avec les clients
donc il faut que les cannes une marche
elle marchera mieux c'est tout le monde
se comprend et s'apprécient voilà c'est
tout ça coûte rien donc encore à
l'appliquer verger je vais donc mettre
aux voix
l'amendement 539 rectifié qui a deux
avis une demande de retrait ou avis
défavorable qui est pour merci contre
merci abstentions l'amendement 539
rectifié abstention oui merci
l'amendement 539 rétifié n'est pas
adopté j'arrive à l'article 2 j'ai trois
demandes de parole madame brigitte
gonthier-maurin madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
une intervention pour vous dire que cet
article 2 nous laisse assez dubitatif
présenté par le gouvernement comme une
avancée supplémentaire pour les salariés
la création du compte individuel de
formation fait cependant l'objet d'un
traitement que l'on peut qualifier de
lapidaire sa création n'est évoquée que
au travers d'une courte phrase prévoyant
je cite afin de favoriser son accès à la
formation professionnelle tout au long
de la vie chaque personne dispose
indépendamment de son statut dès son
entrée sur le marché du travail d'un
compte personnel de formation
individuelle
et intégralement transférables en cas de
changement ou de perte d'emploi fin de
citation de ce compte des modalités de
son abonnement de la manière dont les
salariés peuvent y recourir
nous ne savons rien au point qu'il nous
aura fallu prendre connaissance de
l'article 5 de l'accord national
interprofessionnel qu'il doit
théoriquement retranscrire pour enfin
comprendre qu'il ne s'agit pas de la
création d'un droit nouveau à la
formation professionnelle
meda toilettage au fond et d'une
extension au demeurant assez limité de
la portabilité du droit individuel à la
formation
ce que cet article présente comme un
droit nouveau n'est en fait qu'une
technique nouvelle de gestion des droits
actuels d'eau nous regrettons d'ailleurs
qu'elle ne soit pas plus démocratique
qui plus est l'insertion de cet article
nouveau dans l'article l 61 11-1 du code
du travail dont je rappelle qu'il fixe
les principes généraux de la formation
professionnelle tend à réduire le droit
à la formation professionnelle à ce
compte
faisant fi par exemple de l'importance
pour les actes les salariés des autres
mécanismes de formation comme les plans
de formation il n'y a donc rien de
nouveau sous le soleil de la formation
professionnelle qui malgré la
réaffirmation de son appartenance aux
salariés demeure de fait dans les mains
des employeurs comme pour le droit
individuel à la formation le nombre
d'heures acquises annuellement par les
salariés sera de 20 heures comme pour le
dif le cumul demeurera de 120 heures sur
six ans comme pour le dif un salarié ne
pourra pas immédiatement utiliser les
crédits qu'il aura accumulé sur son
compte sans que son employeur ou le que
le pôle emploi ne l'y autorisent dès
lors on comprend mal comment la création
de ce conte pourrait à lui seul résoudre
les inégalités et les difficultés
générées par le dif est que nous
connaissons par ailleurs pire selon les
interprétations différentes que les
observateurs de l'ani se font de cet
article son adoption pourrait réduire
les droits des salariés
certains considèrent en effet que le rgo
par un salarié de son droit à un congé
individuel de formation aurait pour
effet de vider le compte individuel de
formation des droits qu'il convient
qu'il contient pardon pourriez vous
monsieur le ministre
à cette occasion nous dire ce qu'il en
est réellement
nous sommes donc bien loin d'une
véritable réforme de la formation
professionnelle que nous étions pourtant
nombreux à soutenir a exigé à gauche
lorsque nous examinions le projet de loi
de monsieur xavier bertrand relatif à la
formation professionnelle tout au long
de la vie pour ce faire c'est toute la
formation professionnelle qu'il faut
repenser il faut arrêter avec la logique
de plafonnement des heures qui constitue
une limite considérable aux droits des
salariés particulièrement lorsque l'on
mesure et le prix et le temps qu'exige
les formations qualifiantes qui sont
souvent de longue durée afin de
permettre l'accès à la formation
professionnelle des moins diplômés qui
est quand même une vraie question
il faut permettre à celle-ci et à ceux
ci restent sorti récemment du système
scolaire sans diplôme d'accéder à la
formation et non pas comme cet article
le prévoit la réserver aux personnes
déjà insérés sur le marché du travail
il faut également rendre aux salariés
les pleins pouvoirs quant à
l'utilisation de leurs droits en
supprimant la faculté dont dispose
actuellement l'employeur de refusé à
deux reprises la demande de formation
professionnelle des salariés ceux
d'entre eux qui sont les plus précaires
doivent par ailleurs pouvoir bénéficier
d'une majoration de leurs droits afin
que ceux ci soient plus effectif et que
leur chance d'évoluer
professionnellement soit plus importante
que cela n'est actuellement le cas il
faut enfin renforcer le secteur public
de la formation professionnelle
notamment réaffirmant le rôle majeur de
l'afpa et c'est en cessant de confier la
formation professionnelle des salariés
privés d'emploi à des opérateurs privés
de placement et de formation qui sont
coûteux peu efficace malgré les
sélections qu'ils opèrent quant aux
personnes qu'ils accueillent
de tous ces enjeux l'article 2 ne traite
pas nous y voyons là encore comme pour
l' article 1er la preuve d'un
renoncement celui d'exiger des
employeurs qu'ils jouent pleinement leur
rôle et que par voie de conséquence il
participe financièrement plus qu'ils ne
font aujourd'hui c'est pour toutes ces
raisons que le groupe crc comme sur
l'article 1er premier ne votera pas ce
jeu c'est l'article merci madame madame
la présidente gonthier-maurin madame
parce que madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues je me
réjouis comme je l'avais fait à
l'occasion de l'examen de l'examen par
le sénat du projet de loi relatif aux
emplois d'avenir que les propositions
d'amendement porté notamment par mon
collègue andré chassaigne tendant à
prévoir que la stratégie nationale de
formation professionnelle intègre un
volet spécifique concernant la formation
professionnelle des personnes en
situation de handicap et été adopté
c'est la poursuite dans le domaine de la
formation professionnelle de
l'engagement pris par le gouvernement et
que nous soutenons d'intégrer dans tous
les projets de loi des dispositions
particulières pour ces publics dont on
sait que l'emploi jouent un rôle
fondamental d'un point de vue économique
social mais aussi humain je suis
également sensible à l'adoption des
amendements apportant enfin plus de
précisions sur les conditions
d'utilisation et d'approvisionnement du
compte individuel de formation grâce
auquel on comprend mieux comment il sera
alimenté pour autant malgré l'adoption
de l'amendement déposé par nos collègues
du groupe gdr tendant à préciser que la
formation professionnelle constitue un
élément déterminant de sécurisation des
parcours professionnels et de la
promotion des salariés je regrette que
cet article 2 ne soit qu'une occasion
ratée
la déclaration de principe qui figurent
dans cet article la pelle des
modifications substantielles que les
parlementaires du front de gauche avait
déposé et que nous soutiendrons
également comme vous mes chers collègues
nous considérons que la formation
professionnelle constitue un enjeu
agir pour l'avenir cet égard force est
de constater que l'article 2 ne
permettra pas contrairement à ce que
veut le faire croire l'intitulé de ce
projet de loi à sécuriser les parcours
professionnels des salariés
notre projet ambitieux jeu là vous
repose sur la construction d'un système
de rotation emploi-formation retour à
l'emploi pour chacun librement choisi
permettant une sécurisation des
trajectoires professionnelles de tous
avec maintien et progression du salaire
ce qui n'est pas nécessairement le cas
actuellement
en réalité il s'agit d'élaborer une
sécurité sociale professionnelle à
l'image de celle imaginée en 1945 autour
de la santé de la maternité et de la
famille
l'enjeu est de taille car avec la
sécurité d'emploi et de formation
apparaît aussi la possibilité d'une
sécurisation de tous les moments de la
vie
la progression massive et stable des
prélèvements avec ce système
favoriserait le financement de la
sécurité sociale
contribuant ainsi à une sécurisation et
une promotion de tous les moments
sociaux de la vie de la naissance à la
mort débarrasser la société du chômage
et de la précarité ne peut pas se faire
sans faire preuve d'une audace
comparable à celle dont firent preuve
les créateurs de la sécurité sociale
cela implique des décisions fortes en
renforçant par exemple comme nous allons
le proposer par voie d'amendement les
droits des salariés
cela appellera la mobilisation des
ressources de ressources nouvelles
en taxant notamment le capital et 1
sanctionnant vigoureusement les
employeurs qui font le choix de
favoriser les contrats précaires et la
sous rémunération
voilà pour l'examen de l'article 1 du
projet de loi sur la sécurisation de
l'emploi qui généralise à partir de 2016
la complémentaire santé pour tous les
salariés
vous pourrez évidemment revoir cette
séance à tout instant sur notre site
publicsenat.fr
très bonne journée à vous sur notre
chaîne